earlier today how worried are you that
your region is heading for tier three
well we always always review the
evidence kay always and we'll take
whatever decision
is needed to protect our residents back
in the summer we took a very difficult
decision when the government asked
us to go under restrictions and we did
that but
you know we're in a very different
position to the liverpool city region i
was surprised
to hear all of yesterday the prime
minister and other ministers saying we
were effectively the same we're not
uh in liverpool uh some of the boroughs
have over 600
cases per hundred thousand we we don't
we we don't have anything near that
and the average number of cases here is
quite a lot lower as is the number of
people
uh going into hospital so it's a
different picture but we're not
complacent k
we remain vigilant and we will do what
is needed to protect people
how much pressure are you under from
westminster downing street particularly
in order to move in
to tier three
yes there is uh pressure and it was
certainly piled on
uh yesterday but we have uh serious
doubts
about tier three and let me just explain
what they are two main ones
okay number one there is not a proper
economic support package
not just a local furlough scheme that is
comprehensive but also
no scheme for people who are
self-employed in a wider business
support scheme so
to go into tier three is to accept
significant harm
to the economy and we are not prepared
to do that
in any way lightly but the second
problem is we don't think the evidence
is there
to say that the tier three measures will
get results and actually
the chief medical officer said the same
last night
so this is where this takes me kay in
terms of my
thinking you know is it going to be
better to have
large parts of the country suffering
under tier 3 with all of the economic
harm that that does
with no real results coming from it
which is basically what we were told
last night
or would it be better not to do that and
at some point consider
a circuit break i certainly would prefer
that the latter
rather than places being forced into
tier three
all of the economic damage that comes
with that but without the real results
in tackling the virus and i think that's
the question
for the government this morning so you
would support a national rather than a
regional lockdown
a circuit break uh as proposed by
uh sage i think is preferable
uh to a situation where the government
one by one pile the pressure on local
areas to go into tier three sort of
grind them down and force them into tier
three
as i say that will be a path to
hardship for people redundancies
business failure
now why would we do that lightly why
would we just sort of roll over and
accept that we're not going to do
to do that and what i'm saying is if if
the alternative is
a shorter circuit break then certainly i
would i would much prefer that and i
would support
that over this sort of process of
putting people into tier three and
letting them
suffer away without of the economic
support that they are going to need
we were given the impression by the
mayor of liverpool and the
city region that they didn't really have
much choice and they found themselves in
tier three um they tried to resist they
didn't feel that they were necessarily
supported
by the government as much as they would
want to be what if you're
pushed into it what are you going to do
with your backs against the wall
well i think they're right because i i
obviously have been
privy to some of those conversations
they were given no choice and that's
really important to say we were
it was conceded in our meeting with
downing street that we were in a
different position
to liverpool so i am slightly uh
frustrated at some of the language they
came out with
yesterday and having put in our
proposals to the government
over the weekend we didn't hear anything
back and we were just told we were in
tier two
yesterday so there was no no negotiation
no real engagement so
i don't know that's a strange way i
think for the for the government to go
about things we are in a serious
situation but the question is what will
most work
whilst causing the least damage to the
economy of the north of england and i
think the whole construct of
tier three without that proper uh
economic package coming with it is going
to level down large parts of the north
if we just go with it
and that is why i am arguing back
against it
uh this morning the the government
either changes the support it provides
uh or it considers an alternative route
and i think that basically is where
we're at this morning
yeah i'm asking i suppose on behalf of
my viewers in greater manchester this
morning
if you if their mayor is forced by the
government to go into tier three what
will he do
will he push back and say i'm not going
to do that or will you accept it but
but i believe it's within your
jurisdiction to say
yeah but i'm not going to close the bars
and i'm not going to close the pubs and
i'm not going to close the gyms you can
make that decision
on a regional level is that your
understanding as well and if so is that
what you would do
well i would say to the residents of
great manchester it's not just
me alone and i'm meeting with the ten
council leaders uh this morning to
discuss
uh the situation and we will give it
very careful consideration and
particularly the seriousness
of the health situation we want measures
okay that are going to work
if we do them if we take the pain at
least let's get the results
and the chief medic medical officer told
the country last night that tier three
was pain without results and we're
we're not in favor of that kind of
approach so we will discuss it and we'll
discuss it
carefully and we will do what's right
for greater manchester and its residents
what we don't think is right is to just
accept
that cave into the pressure from the
government accept tier 3
and then expose our residents to all of
the uh the hardship that would come
with that so you know we will stand our
ground we we
act on the evidence at all times uh
we've we've called
uh things often correctly throughout
this you know to hear robert generick
saying oh it's wonderful
you know what councils can do contact
racing this morning he's always come up
with a great idea
we have been saying that all year and he
hasn't been
listening so i'm afraid you know we're
not going to just be
kind of told what to do by the
government we will take our own
decisions this morning
and then we will enter discussions with
the government but as i say
large parts of the poorest parts of the
country
suffering under tier 3 or winter is not
something that appeals to me and the
world health organization
said last week there was one sure thing
about lockdowns they make the forest in
society even poorer
and i'm afraid the government has not
come up with measures that will stop
that happening
yeah i suppose what i'm looking for mr
burnham's clarification for the people
that you are representing that's
obviously why you've come to talk to us
this morning are you saying if downing
street tries to do something in the
northwest that you feel is detrimental
to the health and economic well-being of
the people that you represent you will
ignore them
no i'm not saying that because in the
end the government can impose
and they can impose the law on us so no
i'm not going to get into a pointless
you know gesture politics
what you can do is it is then left up to
the regional decisions is my
understanding i may be wrong that you
can then decide
whether what level of lockdown that
might be in whether the pubs need to
close and
whether the restaurants need to close
and whether or not uh we need to
see gyms closing and that sort of thing
is that your understanding
oh you know that's that's right okay so
what the government are saying that
there'll be a baseline level
so the closure of pubs but then other
things are at local discretion and for
discussion with the government and we'd
like to get back actually
to having a proper discussion with the
government about these things based on
the evidence
we don't have evidence that pubs are
a major cause of spread of the virus and
actually i i come back to something i've
said before
we certainly have growing evidence that
the 10 pm curfew
is actually counterproductive in that it
is creating more social gatherings in
the street
in the supermarket in the home and that
i would say is a further contradiction
in the government's tier
system you know some of its policies are
actually achieving the opposite of what
they want
to achieve so now we've gone through
this sort of pain barrier with the
government let's just now have
proper engagement to sort all these
issues out
but i do think a circuit break could be
a
preferable way of dealing with the
rising number of cases
resetting test and trace rather than
just
everyone being forced into tier three
and that causing just
uh gradual damage to the economy over
the winter
and leaving the north of england
basically shattered on the other side of
this pandemic
okay a final thought before i let you go
over i may please mr mayor
why is the north so much more badly
affected northwest northeast
particularly some
regions uh in the midland as opposed to
london and the southeast
well the deputy chief medical officer
said it yesterday didn't he uh there was
a recognition there that national
lockdown
was lifted too early for the north as
i've consistently
said it was a decision taken more with
london in mind
the lockdown was lifted when cases were
still too high here
then everyone was encouraged down the
pub and to eat out and all of that
and we've struggled to get our cases
down ever since and i think that is when
the story of this is told hey
he's three times higher than it was uh
in london and
i think that explains why the north has
struggled and you know those politicians
who seek to blame the people here
is an easy way of uh of kind of shifting
blame for themselves
i'm afraid got their answer from the
deputy chief medical officer yesterday
but could you not have imposed
a regional lockdown as we saw regional
lockdowns in leicester and the light was
that not your role to do that
we did so we've had a lockdown for 10
weeks
and so the idea being kind of put out
yesterday by the government that we are
somehow weak and we won't take the tough
decisions well
i'm saying we took them 10 weeks ago and
our residents have been under tier 2
style restrictions for all of that
time and that is a big ask of them
actually and to kind of minimize that
i i think is wrong for the government to
to do that so we we've taken those
tough decisions we're just of the view
that we think these
uh halfway house lockdowns of the kind
being proposed in tier two and tier 3
have limited effectiveness i think they
dampen the figures
but they don't bring them back down the
other way i think only
a circuit break would do that and then
out of that a fully functioning
localized test and trace system okay
very quick thought before i let you go
mr mayor
you were previously health secretary of
course i've grilled you many times in
that role how much sympathy do you have
for matt hancock at the moment
well i've said all year that i do you
know no one envies the position that the
government
is in um it's a tough place for them to
be
but in the last few days that sympathy
has won very thin
because they've just been they are
handing down judgments briefing
newspapers
not working truly in partnership with us
you can't
tell everyone who works in pubs in the
north of england that you know 10 p.m on
a wednesday night that their jobs are
gonna
gonna disappear in a few days time and
that that's just arrogance i'm afraid
so i you know i yes i have sympathy but
why do they keep treating people in this
way where they kind of making leaks and
briefs to newspapers without being
being straight with people about what
they're what they're going to do so i
have sympathy
but but i don't appreciate the style
with which they're governing at the
moment